kann ich ausschließen dass alles um mich
rum illusionist treppe generiert ist du
den apparat
ich glaube eigentlich einfach das darum
mit hoher krankenstand sind wo handfest
sind und wo existieren und andere
manager sind da und wir sind pflanzen
sind da hoffe ich dass die großen shows
auch noch nicht gemerkt wenn wirklich so
süchtig fragen die sind so zu groß als
dass mir sicher ich glaube dass einige
zur spitze aber aus experiment
funktioniert natürlich extrem gut
das heißt dass man sich sache findet die
heirat danke schön ist auch spannende
ausgangslage
wenn ich merke dass das ganze nur die
illusion ist
den will ich hasse ich werde wegen wir
die dank internet als system fehler
ausgemerzt
warum geht's naturkatastrophe da hätte
dadurch müssen meter schaffen
aber warum geht es gegen das brauchtum
gibt es deutliche verkehrsunfall
wenn die damen schon machen dann machen
sie doch gut niemand merkt dass heime
ist dann weiß die perfekte show wer so
reagiere aber den tisch nicht wie
politisch